Facebook's top executives are fighting
back against a bombshell New York Times
report the questions how they handled
security issues surrounding the site
Wednesday's report says CEO Mark
Zuckerberg and CEO of Sheryl Sandberg
helped hide problems within Facebook and
used a lobbying firm to attack critics
we were on our way to meet Sandberg for
a sit-down interview in California but
we were grounded by severe weather
instead we spoke to her by phone it's an
interview you'll hear only on CBS this
morning she strongly denied the articles
claim saying quote the allegations in
this piece are very serious and
absolutely false we are more determined
than our opponents and we will keep
fighting when Facebook CEO Sheryl
Sandberg testified to Congress in
September she assured lawmakers Facebook
leadership was focused on security for
its more than 2 billion users when
content violates our policies we will
take it down but according to a New York
Times article Facebook's top executives
not only ignored warning signs of
Russian interference in 2016 but sought
to conceal them from public view in an
exclusive interview by phone
Sandberg told us the article saying that
I was spending time hiding deflecting or
hiring PR firms to do other things
that's just all not true adding I wasn't
involved in any of that on a conference
call with reporters yesterday CEO Mark
Zuckerberg echoed Sandberg's denial
suggest that we weren't interested in
knowing the truth or that we wanted to
hide what we knew or that we try to
prevent investigations is simply untrue
The Times investigation detailed
Facebook's work with the Washington
consulting firm definers public affairs
which reportedly influenced articles
blasting Apple and Google and played
down the impact of the Russians use of
Facebook the firm also allegedly tried
to discredit activist protesters by
linking them to Democratic billionaire
donor and philanthropist George Soros
Sandberg told us Facebook never paid for
fake news and that the firm was hired
not to smear anyone not to get any
articles written or do anything false
when we pressed her on why she didn't
know about definers role as an
opposition research firm at the company
she responded I certainly wish I had
question still remains what did they do
and how much money did they spend on it
and did they spend it against elected
officials senator Amy Klobuchar joined
three other Democratic senators urging
the Department of Justice to look into
Facebook's lobbying techniques but for
now Samberg says she is aggressively
looking into what happened when asked if
she has the confidence of Mark
Zuckerberg and the rank-and-file
employees at Facebook she told us yes I
believe so and as for the security
issues she said it's on me on us to
figure out what those are
trust takes a long time to rebuild we
know we have a long road ahead and we
don't expect it to happen overnight in
response to the New York Times report
the Washington firm told us it's work
was entirely factual and based on public
records
now since the articles released George
Soros and others have called for
Facebook to have an independent
investigation Sandberg declined to say
whether they would launch such an
investigation saying only they're
looking into it Facebook does say it is
now evaluating all the firms they have
hired and what they exactly do so
there's more to come on this you hear a
lot from employees within the firm
saying posting yesterday on chat rooms
internal that this company has lost its
moral compass questions about whether
advertisers will boycott Facebook
Facebook makes a lot of money from its
advertisers there's still a lot of
questions that remain but now though
Sheryl has the support of not only Mark
Zuckerberg but the board as well
absolutely the board did offered some of
their support yesterday on this they're
gonna remain so far in their position
but this doesn't end and I want you to
see we we hope to sit down with Sheryl
Sandberg as we reported this was this
Terrell so we really only got about 12
minutes on the phone with her so we got
as many questions as we could in we
posted that on CBS this morning dot-com
and you don't have to have hope to have
more time with Sheryl to discuss this
further I'm hoping she'll talk to you
next week because Nora this story is not
going away there's still so many
questions but for now they mark and
Sheryl do seem to have the support of
the rank-and-file as well you talk to
the people there I mean that's not clear
there are people raising concerns she
says she believes that they have the
support of the rank-and-file
they do have the support of the board
and and the two problems are the one
this ongoing question whether they were
aware and on top of the security
questions but then this new bit about
whether they took aggressive defensive
measures - - and that's the stuff that's
really got her in the hot seat right now
so as a CEO what should she have been
aware of now she's saying she wasn't big
question as well that a lot of
Washington politicians have yes an
interview yeah